merci lors d'un coup de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure élu de
l'Essonne vous êtes nombreux les
républicains vice-présidente de la
Commission de la culture et de
l'éducation et on a pas mal de sujets à
vos rêves avec vous et on commence par
la réforme des retraites puisque deux
décrets pardon sont parus hier au
Journal officiel dont celui portant
l'âge légal de départ à 64 ans est-ce
que le gouvernement a eu raison de les
publier à ce moment-là deux jours avant
une nouvelle journée de mobilisation je
pense que le gouvernement suisse à
logique et montrer sa détermination sans
faille
aller jusqu'au bout donc mais je
partage l'opinion de certains de dire
que c'était peut-être pas on n'était pas
à deux jours près et qu'on pouvait
attendre j'allais dire la fin de cette
séquence de du vote de de cette
proposition de loi de du groupe lyaute
je trouve que je dis ça marquera la fin
de cette séquence après le débat passé à
l'Assemblée je le pense alors après bien
évidemment moi étant parlementaire je
respecte avant tout le Parlement et je
trouve qu'en il faut aller jusqu'au bout
de de ce vote là où Charles de Courson a
eu raison depuis le début c'est
peut-être sur la dans la méthode pour
préparer cette cette loi retraite on
aurait pu s'y prendre autrement moi je
pense qu'on a fait un très bon travail
au Sénat notamment sous l'impulsion de
notre groupe sénatorial donc c'est un
petit peu on est un peu amer parce que
finalement tout ça est passé un peu à
l'AS par rapport à ce qui s'est passé
ensuite
je pense que les Français ne comprennent
absolument rien à la procédure
parlementaire l'article 40 ce qui s'est
passé en commission le fait que la
présidente pourrait ne pas aller
jusqu'au vote je pense qu'il faut que la
procédure aille jusqu'au bout je ne sais
pas si la mobilisation se rapporte
demain mais ça veut dire procédé que il
faut que la procédure est jusqu'au bout
ça veut dire qu'elle brune pilée ne doit
pas dégainer
je pense je pense qu'il faudrait aller
jusqu'au vote
j'espère que dans le groupe LR il n'y
aura pas autant de députés que la
dernière fois
je préférerais que les députés comme
nous se consacrent à demander la loi
travail
j'aurais préféré d'ailleurs que cette
loi travail soit avant cette loi
retraite ça nous aurait permis de
pouvoir vraiment réformer les carrières
longues les carrières des femmes sur
lesquelles j'avais beaucoup travaillé au
moment de la réforme sur les retraites
je pense qu'on a mis la charrue avant
les boeufs et donc passons peut-être à
autre chose de toute façon le
gouvernement ira jusqu'au bout et
essayons d'améliorer cette loi travail
pour que
on puisse vraiment améliorer les
carrières qui qui doivent être mais ça
veut dire juste que vous ne comprendriez
pas les députés les républicains qui
votent pour la proposition de loi en
effet depuis le début je ne l'ai jamais
compris je la suis entièrement je me
suis fait agresser comme d'autres au
moment de de du passage de de du texte
au Sénat dans dans mon département
la droite prône la retraite à 65 ans
depuis trois présidentielles enfin il
faut qu'on a quand même jusqu'au bout de
notre logique je vous dis la méthode
n'était peut-être été brutale c'est sûr
mais moi je reste fidèle à une certaine
cohérence d'idées parce que quand on
voit nos pays les pays voisins ils sont
déjà bien au-delà et je pense que mon
n'avait pas le choix bon vous connaissez
vous Charles de Courson est-ce que vous
trouvez que lui il reste fidèle à une
certaine cohérence d'idée alors
il était quand même il y a quelques
années aussi pour cette retraite enfin
au prolongement de de
des années de travail d'annuité mais je
pense qu'il a voulu surtout
accentuer la méthode enfin le problème
de méthode pendant toute la durée de
cette de ce texte
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour lui c'est
un des parlementaires les plus anciens
pas les plus vieux mais les plus anciens
moi je l'ai connu comme quand j'étais
attaché parlementaire d'un député UDF
dans les années 90 donc au début des
années 90 mais donc j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour lui je je trouve que
il n'est pas non plus totalement logique
avec avec ce qui prenait il y a quelques
années voilà si jamais vous vous
souhaitez pas accueillir le point de
Pivet dégâts de l'article 40 jeudi si
elle fait est-ce que pour vous il y a un
risque de crise institutionnelle voire
de crise démocratique
c'est c'est dans le enfin je veux dire
c'est la Constitution donc elle a le
droit de le faire je trouve ça serait
une provocation
peut-être en effet
inutile
avant tout du Parlement parce que je
pense que les Français je vous dis ne
comprendraient pas enfin nous vont
comprennent pas forcément cette article
mais donc du Parlement et donc j'allais
dire des Français
allons jusqu'au bout de cette logique et
je vous dis tournons la page je l'espère
à la fin de à la fin de la semaine
l'autre sujet d'actualité c'est la
question du harcèlement scolaire vous
suivez ces dossiers au Sénat à peine le
ministre de l'éducation nationale va
recevoir cet après-midi la famille de la
jeune unité 13 ans qui s'est suicidé
victime de harcèlement scolaire est-ce
qu'il y a eu pour vous défaillance de
l'état de l'éducation nationale
le terme est très fort je comprends très
très bien les parents de de cette jeune
lycée
d'ailleurs qu'ils aillent au bout de
leur plaindre je pense que c'est
important même pour la suite
défaillance mais surtout encore
pas assez de formation et de
compréhension de de ces sujets là et du
pharmacien des professeurs formation des
professeurs de l'entoure enfin je veux
dire de de tout l'entourage du
de toute l'équipe éducative parce que
c'est aussi les CPE c'est
le ça peut être le secrétariat du
principal de collège mais également les
parents
pour en arriver à ce qu'a fait
dramatiquement cette petite Lindsay
il y a eu sûrement beaucoup d'alerte
avant et il faut rien minimiser moi je
suis aussi concert départemental et donc
je siège dans des conseils
administrations de collège je me suis
vraiment mis en colère
il y a quelques mois parce que sur une
groupe WhatsApp de d'élèves
un jeune à juste dit à sa à sa une de
ses collègues enfin de ces camarades de
classe ont égorgera comme on a égorgé le
mouton à l'Aïd mais parce que c'était un
groupe WhatsApp
hors du cadre scolaire quand il a posté
son message il n'a eu aucun blâme pas de
passage en conseil de discipline et tout
ça paraît très logique j'ai sensibilisé
et les parents et les professeurs qui
étaient au conseil en disant mais vous
ne vous rendez pas compte si on ne met
pas le haut là tout de suite sur ce
genre alors là c'est un acte de violence
et même c'est même pas simplement du
harcèlement je trouve que c'est aberrant
et de la même façon je trouve aberrant
que ça soit l'enfant harcelé qui soit
objet souvent de quitter l'établissement
plutôt que le harceleur tout ça entraîne
en fait des générations de jeunes qui
vont avoir cette phobie scolaire de ne
plus pouvoir entrer alors on a fait une
Intex
au Sénat l'année dernière
lui-même semble aller complètement dans
notre sens Olivier Pacaud avait fait un
très bon rapport donc pour accentuer le
délit dans le code pénal de harcèlement
mais très honnêtement enfin je veux dire
il faut entourer la personne la victime
peut-être en effet susciter plus c'était
moins pour sensibiliser même les
camarades de classe mais il faut aussi
quand même empêcher le harceleur de
continuer ailleurs voilà et ça pour ça
malheureusement il n'y a rien de
de de plus fort que de d'essayer
d'accentuer le délit quoi ça entraîne
aussi des phobies scolaires vous arrivez
à chiffrer ce phénomène à savoir à peu
près ce que ça représente ou c'est
compliqué alors c'est très compliqué
parce que les bien sûr l'éducation
nationale ne
poste pas ce genre en fin de pas
d'études là-dessus mais j'ai discuté
avec une amie
psychiatre à Bordeaux qui est en train
justement de travailler sur une
expérimentation avec l'Académie de
Bordeaux et donc son hôpital en
psychiatrique et la phobie scolaire
arrive de plus en plus tôt et donc ça
n'est pas un caprice de la part de
l'enfant c'est souvent la peur au ventre
de vouloir retourner à l'école
le covid aussi a accentué ça parce que
la désociabilisation a fait que c'était
plus compliqué mais c'est très important
et le cyber-harcèlement
dans la loi et dans le rapport de
l'évier Pacaud on en a beaucoup parlé
parce que ça vient à partir de là vous
avez vu qu'on a beaucoup beaucoup
travaillé aussi sur ces sujets je pense
que les nos jeunes se rendent absolument
pas compte de la violence verbale et et
d'image
qu'il voit tous les jours et donc la
violence de des propos il la vie au
quotidien et sa sœur de leur bouche on
va voir l'actualité dans votre
département et dans votre région
maintenant on retrouve Jacques paquet
bonjour Jacques merci d'être avec nous
directeur de la rédaction du journal du
Grand Paris Jacques on va parler
transport avec vous et d'abord vous
souhaitiez revenir sur cette
consultation publique sur l'idée de voie
de périphérique réservée
tout à fait bonjour Comme vous le savez
madame darkos la mairie de Paris
souhaite pérennisé au-delà des Jeux
Olympiques la voix réservée à la fois
sur le boulevard périphérique mais aussi
sur la 1 et la 13 la voie réservée aux
athlètes et aux personnalités de des
Jeux Olympiques ça crée de la polémique
il y a une enquête une concertation qui
vient de s'achever Clément bonne s'est
exprimé en disant qu'il était ouvert à
l'idée mais qu'il demandait qu'une étude
d'impact soit réalisé quelle est votre
position je crois que vous faites partie
des gens qui n'adhéraient pas totalement
à cette idée merci merci beaucoup pour
votre question non ça c'est sûr et j'ai
quand Vincent Jean Brun et d'autres
doses nous ont sollicité pour signer
cette pétition en tout cas contre la
fermeture des enfin de la pérennisation
périnée pérennisation de de cette
fermeture des voix des d'une voix sur le
périphérique je l'ai signé dès demain
c'est une fois de plus couper les
Franciliens de la capitale alors vous
allez dire que c'est des gens qui
pourraient prendre les moyens de
transport RER
Tram Train etc bon pour améliorer les
transports mais il reste encore quelques
années difficiles à vivre pour les
Franciliens je le vois tous les jours
sur les boucles des réseaux sociaux mais
moi je pense même à des artisans les
artisans n'ont absolument pas les moyens
de vivre dans la capitale ils vivent en
périphérie et c'est une ça devient de
plus en plus galère pour eux de rentrer
à Paris pour pour faire un un petit
chantier mais ça ça va de réparer votre
chaudière à refaire simplement un
des travaux de tuyauterie donc on est en
train une fois plus de couper la
banlieue de la capitale je veux dire
regarde tout à l'heure j'étais
extrêmement choquée aux Journées du
Patrimoine en septembre dernier la de
Paris a choisi c'est celui-là pour faire
ses journées sans voiture ça veut dire
que aucun francilien a participé à un
RER un dimanche non plus aller visiter
un monument ou un musée parisien ce
weekend là c'est juste absolument
scandaleux donc en effet on est nombreux
à être contre
est-ce que il vous semble est-ce qu'il
vous semble que c'est une mauvaise
réponse à une bonne question parce que
par ailleurs Valérie Pécresse c'est
l'argument d'ailleurs de l'exécutif
parisien soutien elle-même le
covoiturage
lié en fait à la à la à la au à l'impact
sur la santé que qu'à la circulation
automobile oui mais ce que prône Valérie
Pécresse ou même mon président de
département François du Rouvray c'est
d'avoir des des
dédiées de bus pour la fluidité des des
transports mais mais pas la condamnation
à un moment donné d'une voix complète
c'est très très différent et le
covoiturage bien évidemment on
l'encourage tous
de nos vœux et ça fonctionne d'ailleurs
il y a de plus en plus d'air de
covoiturage même dans mon département
c'est très très différent là c'est c'est
vraiment
comme elle le fait sur les berges ou
autres condamné des des lignes entières
donc même pas en fait pour des
transports dédiés donc je je pense que
c'est plus radical et à mon avis pas
donc ça va pas dans le bon sens toujours
toujours côté transport Jacques la
Société du Grand Paris change de nom
qu'est-ce que ça change
alors
exactement c'est toute la question que
que je souhaite
Patrice avoir son regard sur cette
[Musique]
sur ce qu'elle est d'importance
potentielle très grande c'est-à-dire que
la Société du Grand Paris va être
rebaptisée la société des grands projets
et vous avez vous y référence au RER
parisien mais le gouvernement souhaite
créer comme vous le savez un réseau de
RER métropolitain en province je crois
que c'est une dizaine de réseaux et donc
va confier à la Société du Grand Paris
la responsabilité de cette coordination
la Société du Grand Paris donc change de
nom j'aurais voulu savoir vous vous êtes
vous êtes élu aussi de l'Essonne je
pense à la ligne 18 je pense que vous y
êtes attaché puisqu'elle doit relier
Orly à au Plateau de Saclay qui est un
territoire tout à fait stratégique pour
le pour l'Île-de-France et pour la
France est-ce que vous faites partie
madame darkos des des élus franciliens
qui s'inquiète de cette de cette
extension de des de cette élargissement
des missions de la SGP en redoutant une
dilution à la fois du poids des des élus
franciliens dans le administration de la
société
conseil de surveillance je crois je sais
plus comment il s'appelle et d'autre
part et surtout d'une dilution des
crédits
alors c'est une vase se question en
quelques minutes bien sûr que j'ai suivi
énormément tous les travaux de la ligne
18 puisque c'est mon territoire
d'élection donc je le suis depuis
longtemps on a eu pendant quelques
années des vraies difficultés dialogues
entre les élus et la Société du Grand
Paris c'était vraiment dû aux dirigeants
d'une certaine manière qui
se comportait comme l'état dans l'état
et c'est vrai que du coup il y a eu
d'ailleurs des erreurs qui ont été
faites où on aurait pu peut-être
dialoguer un peu plus en amont de faire
une ligne 18 en souterrain plutôt que de
en extérieur aujourd'hui on a une
gouvernance qui fonctionne bien avec des
dirigeants de la Suisse du Grand Paris
qui sont vraiment dans le dialogue je le
vois pour la ligne 18 elle est pas
facile à accepter pour les pour les
habitants mais il y a un dialogue
permanent même avec les agriculteurs
pour qu'on puisse faire des des chemins
enfin des des accidents de traverse pour
que ils bien sûr accéder à leur à leur
chant et alors
et alors voilà le lieu de travail le
changement de nom c'est que mais
j'espère quand même qu'il finiront avant
tous les travaux franciliens c'est ma
seule inquiétude j'avais dit avant
d'avoir l'ambition de le faire pour les
autres régions ils nous en ont parlé ça
n'a jamais été un secret mais s'il reste
dans ce même esprit de co-gouvernance
avec les élus ils auront montré un
savoir-faire enfin moi je suis fasciné
par les grands travaux il fait que en
effet ils sont peut-être assez capés
pour pouvoir maintenant s'attaquer
j'allais dire aux autres travaux des des
autres grandes métropoles mais je
souhaite avant tout que la ligne 18 et
les autres lignes franciliennes soit
terminée on a déjà pris beaucoup
beaucoup de retard donc mais il a même
façon on le sait moins ils ont sur le
plan culturel des grands projets à faire
dans chaque gare donc c'est quand même
aussi des gens qui
dialogue aussi sur d'autres sujets que
simplement de faire des voix et des
tunnels merci Jacques paquet merci
d'avoir été avec nous elle a une journal
du Grand Paris c'est le géographe Daniel
Béart renoncer au modèle unique de
l'agglomération chef-lieu c'est à la Une
du journal du Grand Paris merci beaucoup
Jacques paquet on va parler des
sénatoriales lors d'Archos elles auront
lieu le 24 septembre et cette semaine
seront désignés une partie des grands
électeurs notre journaliste alex pusard
va tout nous expliquer du fonctionnement
de ces élections
[Musique]
début de semaine tous nous expliquer du
fonctionnement des sénatoriales comment
ça marche oui c'est un fonctionnement
assez complexe alors on va d'abord
commencer par les fondamentaux
effectivement c'est prochaine élections
sénatoriales ont lieu le dimanche 24
septembre lors de ces élections c'est la
moitié du Sénat qui va être renouvelée
170 sièges de sénateurs sont remis en
jeu sur 348 au total et chaque sénateur
est élu pour un mandat de 6 ans du coup
tous les départements du territoire
français ne sont pas concernés par ces
élections sénatoriales seuls les
départements du numéro 37 au numéro 66
sont concernés cette année c'est à dire
de l'Indre-et-Loire aux
Pyrénées-Orientales et puis également
les départements d'Île-de-France
d'outre-mer et 6 sièges de sénateurs des
Français établis en France sur 12 seront
renouvelées et Alex qui est l'île les
sénateurs alors ce ne sont pas les
citoyens ce n'est pas niveau ni moi
c'est un collège de grands électeurs
désignés dans chaque département c'est
ce qu'on appelle le suffrage universel
indirect en septembre environ 80
000 grands électeurs vont s'exprimer il
y a essentiellement dans ce collège de
grands électeurs des élus locaux à 95%
de conseils municipaux et puis le reste
est composé de conseiller départementaux
régionaux et également des
parlementaires autre complexité de ces
sénatoriales le mode de scrutin il varie
en fonction des départements dans les
départements peuplés qui élisent un
sénateur ou deux sénateurs l'élection se
fait au scrutin uni nominal un candidat
majoritaire à deux tours ça veut dire
que et bien le dimanche 24 septembre au
matin il y aura le premier tour avec
tous les candidats et le dimanche
après-midi le second tour entre les deux
finalistes et puis dans les départements
plus peuplés qui élisent trois sénateurs
ou plus le scrutin se fait à la
proportionnelle à un tour il y a donc
des listes de candidats et les listes
qui remportent le plus de voix de grands
électeurs se répartissent les sièges de
sénateurs du département et Alex va nous
parler de l'enjeu de ces élections pour
les groupes politiques
les sénateurs sont élus à 95% par des
conseillers municipaux et bien quand on
regarde le résultat des dernières
élections municipales en 2020 cela donne
un aperçu du résultat possible de ces
élections sénatoriales 2023 la majorité
du Sénat qui est constitué à des
républicains et du centre ne devrait pas
vraiment bouger car la droite et le
Centre ont et bien conquis obtenu une
majorité de communes aux dernières
municipales certains groupes pourraient
gagner des sièges chez le cas du groupe
que vous voyez en vert le groupe
écologiste qui pourrait gagner certains
sièges car les écologistes ont fait de
bons scores aux dernières municipales le
groupe les indépendants en gris peut
aussi gagner des sièges puisque il aura
des candidats horizon horizon le parti
d'Édouard Philippe qui est bien implanté
localement en revanche certains groupes
du Sénat certains groupes politiques du
Sénat sont en danger notamment le groupe
communiste qui a actuellement 15 sièges
on le rappelle il faut au moins 10
sièges pour avoir un groupe politique au
Sénat et
bien le groupe communiste pourrait
perdre quelques sièges de sénateur ce
sera l'un des enjeux et puis dernier
enjeu on verra si le rassemblement
national qui est actuellement n'a pas de
sénateurs réussis à conquérir quelques
sièges de sénateurs il pourrait en
grappiller notamment dans certains
départements le Nord le Pas-de-Calais la
Moselle mais il ne devrait pas faire de
grandes personnes comme on l'a vu au
dernier législative lors d'Archos quel
est l'enjeu de ces élections
sénatoriales pour la majorité de droite
et du centre plus que le nombre de
sièges qui ne devrait pas vraiment
évoluer est-ce que ce n'est pas le
positionnement politique vis-à-vis
d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce qu'il faut être
constructif ou vraiment se montrer dans
l'opposition vis-à-vis des grands
électeurs vous me demandez la voix
peut-être majoritaire de mon groupe ou
la mienne parce que je
non mais vous savez bien en effet que
c'est la grande question même au sein au
sein de nos parties nos partis
politiques moi je pense qu'on va pas
pouvoir rester quatre ans dans cette
situation en tout cas l'Assemblée
nationale et que le Sénat se pose en
sage
au-delà d'être simplement dans la
chambre des territoires c'est pour ça
que vous parlez du fait que ça soit des
grands les grands électeurs soient nos
élus et nos conseillers municipaux je
pense que il va falloir qu'on travaille
vraiment quand même avec le gouvernement
mais que le gouvernement Vienne plutôt
sur nos propositions plutôt que
l'inverse ça serait absolument l'idéal
pour vous il faut un accord de
gouvernement
parce que la corde gouvernement je pense
que vraiment le président a loupé le
coche en fait au lendemain des élections
législatives le Dean n'était pas aussi
ouvert que ça je le regrette parce que
j'en ai fait j'aurais été de ceux qui
l'auraient accepté mais le dit n'était
quand même très déséquilibré maintenant
je pense qu'en effet il va falloir qu'on
travaille on travaille avec eux on le
voit pour l'immigration
le ministre Darmanin a l'air plutôt
d'accord avec nous nos propositions à
mon avis vont un petit peu trop loin sur
la constitue enfin le l'aspect
constitutionnel vis-à-vis des des du
droit européen ça c'est mon avis
personnel mais en tout cas on est quand
même assez aligné
sur ce point je pense qu'il va falloir
en effet qu'on travaille qu'on travaille
ensemble après voilà donc dans cette
campagne satoriale il faut afficher
selon vous cette volonté de travailler
avec le gouvernement et justement est-ce
que le fait que la majorité de droits de
sénatoriales et voter la réforme des
retraites est-ce que ça ne peut pas
porter préjudice aux candidats de droite
dans cette campagne alors que il y a
quand même une fronde sociale contre ce
texte oui mais alors je vous dis moi mes
élus m'ont absolument jamais parlé de
problème des retraites à part quelques
élus elle est fille dont je de toute
façon je ne
souhaitais pas d'ailleurs avoir en voix
il me parle zan donc zéro
artificialisation nette finance publique
des peaux sauvages agressions sur les
élus donc honnêtement ça ne va pas du
tout être un enjeu de campagne comme de
la même façon la question de se pose pas
sur ce que vous venez de dire et ce qui
on va travailler ou pas avec le
gouvernement la campagne sénatorial
c'est une campagne vraiment de terrain
où les gens ou les élus vont nous
demander comment vous allez faire pour
continuer à améliorer nos problèmes
quotidiens notamment la loi SRU sur les
logements sociaux et autres et donc
influencer le gouvernement pour que on
puisse aller quand même un peu plus dans
le sens des élus donc vraiment centré
sur on parle de l'Essonne
oui alors on le rappelle dans les scènes
il y a cinq sièges de sénateurs qui sont
actuellement acquis à la majorité de
droite et du centre avec trois sièges de
sénateurs Centris de siège de sénateurs
de la républicains d'abord une question
lors d'Archos est-ce que vous êtes
candidate à votre élection oui je l'ai
pas encore dit officiellement dans dans
la presse de l'Essonne mais ce n'est un
secret pour personne oui je repars pour
un deuxième mandat j'espère qu'on mes
élus les élus de l'Essonne me font la
confiance et l'honneur de me de Me
réélire j'ai adoré ce mandat dans un
deuxième mandat on connaît en maîtrise
encore un peu mieux les arcanes de du
Parlement et je pense qu'on a tous tous
les cinq fait très bien notre notre job
et en fait on est connu des 2500 grands
électeurs maintenant on est en campagne
mais quand on a bien fait son job en
étant sur le terrain et au côté de ses
élus bah c'est en une sorte de
de
d'élection de campagne un peu
obligatoire mais on a bien on a bien
fait notre travail maintenant
malheureusement on part tous divisé ce
que vous dites 5 de la majorité il y a
quand même une sénatrice qui siège au
groupe centrisme et qui est modèle et
qui voilà qui devrait être sur il y aura
pas d'union vous faites vous ferez une
ligne vœu depuis vraiment plusieurs mois
après bien évidemment le la difficulté
est toujours le le placement dans une
liste et d'être entre guillemets à la
troisième ou quatrième place quand c'est
plus compliqué mais je pense que c'est
un
par rapport à la dernière fois parce que
la gauche a regagné 18 communes et
qu'elle risque d'être unie et donc on
risque de revoir la gauche de nouveau au
Sénat la gauche et sonnienne ça veut
dire que c'est
les LR et les centrices qui vont perdre
un siège je le crains on va on va tout
faire pour que ça soit pas le cas mais
c'est vrai que cette union n'a pas pu se
faire je n'en porterai pas la
responsabilité seule de cette désunion
parce que je vous dis je pense que j'ai
été de ça qu'ils l'ont appelé le plus de
ses vœux mais en effet je pense oui mais
je pense qu'en effet ça va être ça va
être compliqué de refaire le carton
plein merci Alex à tout à l'heure on
parlera de la gauche anti-up allez on
parlera de tout ça ce sera dans le club
merci lors d'Archos merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité pendant cette
première demi heure merci dans 20
minutes dans le club des territoires on
recevra le président indépendantiste de
la Polynésie française il vient tout
juste d'être élu il est en déplacement à
Paris où il va rencontrer plusieurs
ministres il sera notre invité mais
d'abord on va accueillir Jean-Philippe
Tanguy